कि नमस्कार जर्मनी के हिंदी में कि
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
इंच अदरक हंस इसमें हम एक इंपोर्टेंट पर
बहुत ही इजी कंसेप्ट सीखने वाले हैं वह है
इन डिफरेंट पुराणों में है तो यह नाम
थोड़ा हार्ड लगता है इसलिए डायरेक्ट उसके
अंदर घुसते हैं कि कौन-कौन से तीन सीखने
वाले हैं हम मान यह मांड निर्माण एकदम
सिंपल हैं हम एक के बाद एक सीखना शुरू
करते हैं तो सबसे पहले देख लो मान अभी
पहले स्पेयरिंग नहीं कि लोग हमने अभी तक
एमएलए डबल एन उदयन मतलब मैन इसके ऐसे देखा
है यह थोड़ा सा अलग है यह मेन है और इसका
जो मीनिंग है न वह इंग्लिश में वन की तरह
है उसका हिंदी मीनिंग ओर डायरेक्टली से
नहीं है कि मतलब डायरेक्ट उसका ट्रांसलेशन
करना मुश्किल है आदमी ने या इंसान ने ऐसा
करना चाहिए बोल सकते हो एग्जांपल है
हुआ था वन मस्ट लर्न जर्मन वन मस्ट लर्न
जर्मन मतलब क्या किसी ने तो मतलब ही जर्मन
चिकना अच्छी बात है उसका मीनिंग है तो आप
टेक्निकल हिंदी में कर सकते हैं जिसकी भाई
आदमी ने जर्मन सीखनी चाहिए समझ नहीं पाई
थर्ड पर्सन सिंगुलर वह तो थर्ड पर्सन है
पर कौन है पता नहीं पर उसका बेसिक मीनिंग
क्या है कि जर्मन ठीक है अच्छी बात है वन
मस्ट नॉट मिला है वह झूठ बोलना नहीं चाहिए
किसने किसी ने भी नहीं बोलना चाहिए समझ
रहे हो सदस्य बेसिक कंसेप्ट अगर आपकी
इंग्लिश क्यों व
यह प्रोडक्ट चकली माइन कंसिस्टिंग जर्मन
थोड़े से टेस्ट करके देखते हैं तो थोड़ा
सा इजी हो जाएगा ओके तो सबसे पहले मस्ट
लर्न जर्मन वन मस्ट लर्न जर्मन तो क्या
होगा मांग मुसद्दी लाल मिर्च लेबनान एकदम
सिंपली स्लाइड विमान जैसे मैंने दो
इस पृष्ठ की तरह से
है वैसे ही आ वन मस्ट बे पोलाइट मतलब आदमी
ने पॉइंट करना चाहिए तो क्या होगा मानुष्य
पुलिस अजवाइन या फिर आदमी ने झूठ नहीं
बोलना चाहिए मतलब हां यह वन शोल्ड नॉट वन
शोल्ड नॉट अलाइव तो क्या होगा मान जॉइंट
अनिष्ट फलों अ सिकुड़ हार्ड सेंटेंस करके
देखते हैं वन नीड्स मोडिफिकेशन इन वन वांट
टो लर्न जर्मन वन वंडर्स नोटिफिकेशन इवन
वांट टो लर्न जर्मन तो क्या होगा देखो मान
ब्राउज़र मान प्राउड फील गुड ओल्ड व्हेन
उद्धव चिल्ड्रन विल मांग भरो फील गुड ओल्ड
व्हेन उर ऑयल दिन थे विल एंड सिंपल है
राइट अभी देखिए एक छोटी सी चीज है कि जैसे
हमने बोला था कि वन मस्ट लर्न जर्मन यह मु
कि जर्मनी बोल सकते हैं ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर
मीनिंग डार्विन इजी ब्रांड की बीयर मिशन
लांच लेबनान पर देखो जवाब बोलते हो कि वन
मस्त तो एक लेवल अमोलक है सुधर स्वर्गीय
अफेयर लेवल इसीलिए वन का यूज अगर आप करोगे
तो ऐसा लगेगा क्या क्लिक हियर लेवल के
प्रति है वैसे ही मान मतलब वन था वैसे ही
लेमन यह माल मतलब संबंध यह मानव मतलब समवन
पलक कैसे फिक्स यूज करके देखते हैं तो
एकदम आपको समझ में आ जाएगा कि भाई सब वन
मस्ट हेल्प मार न किसी ने जो करनी चाहिए
उसकी हेल्प sum1 मस्ट हेल्प मार तो क्या
होगा यह माइंड उस मार्क हेल्परिन अगिन
थर्ड पर्सन सिंगुलर सिर्फ चीज क्या है यह
मांड जज जो होता है ना वह सब नॉमिनेटिव
में है तो यह माल है जब वह पॉजिटिव होगा
तो यह माउंटेन होगा और डाट यूरो का तो यह
मार डेम होगा जैस
मीडियम आंच मीडियम हुआ था वैसे आपको किसी
आज होंगे इसीलिए हमने भी थोड़ा लेट सीखा
है यह माइलेज यह मांडल यह मुमेंटम तो हम
अभी आपको संयुक्त सेंटेंस देखते हैं ही
मस्ट मीट समवन ए गेम ऑफिसर यह मॉनिटरी फंड
एवं उसके मन डैंड्रफ क्योंकि इसमें की
सब्जेक्ट है संबंध ऑब्जेक्ट है और वैसे ही
वे मस्ट प्ले विद समवन वे मस्ट प्ले विद
समवन विद क्या होता है डोंट यू इसलिए क्या
होगा यह मैडम दिए और मिसन मिनट यह मान
डम्स क्लन सिंपल है राइड और वैसे ही
सम्मान के उल्टा नॉन नॉन होता है नीमन
नीमन नीमन किसी यूज करना देखते हो कि किसी
ने भी मार्ग की मदद नहीं कि नो बड़ी अ
हेल्प हमारा तो क्या होगा नीम मांड खट्टर
मार्गी होल फन किसी ने दिमाग की मदद नहीं
की नींव वर्क ओं
है तो उससे क्या होगा कि इस लिए मार
ग्लव्स मॉर्गन मार क्लोज दोनों हाथों का
यह मार्क प्ले लिस्ट ईंधन टोटल क्योंकि
मार्च सब्जेक्ट है नीम object ओके वैसे ही
मार्केट प्लेस विद 90 मार्क पीड़ित मिनट
नी पधारो क्यों क्योंकि डाइजेस्टिव सिस्टम
सिंपल है आपको क्या याद रखना है कि मां का
यूज करना है यह यूज करना है और निर्माण का
यूज करना है अब यह देखिए वह सारे जो है वह
डिफरेंट पर्सन 3 छोटे से पौन इंच के लिए
कि देखते हैं कि यह आपको पता है इसलिए मैं
आपको दे रहा हूं मतलब समथिंग मतलब कुछ
मतलब नथिंग कुछ भी नहीं है
का आलेख मतलब एवरीथिंग सब कुछ इसके
छोटे-छोटे एग्जांपल देखते हैं तो आपको यह
पता चल जाएगा तो पहले क्या होगा हाथों
एडवांस गई है और कुछ सुना कि तुमने हेव ईट
समथिंग हाईट 21 वर्ष की ओर इशारा वंश गेल
और आई वांट नथिंग समय एडवांस लिस्ट वैसे
यह
इन सब का सब कुछ मुझे अकेले ही करना पड़ता
है आई वास डूइंग एवरीथिंग अलोन क्या होगा
इस मुसल्ले डेडलाइन मखन गुफा लिए तरह
मक्खन नेटवर्क मतलब कुछ टिप्स मतलब नथिंग
लेस मतलब सब कुछ सिंपल एसिड इंपोर्टेंट
क्या था कि मां का यूज से थोड़ा सा अलग से
है और यह यूज करना न करना मां का भी
कभी-कभी आप उसको पूरा में करके और वो यूज
नहीं इसकी जरूरत नहीं है इंपोर्टेंट चीज
है कि जो इंडिया में थर्ड पर्सन सिंगुलर
में मांग यह कैसे यूज़ करते हो
कि मुझे आशा है कि आप कोई कंसेप्ट समझ में
आई होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में
दो